the hogwarts legacy hype train continues
to roll on as more and more information
is slowly trickling out for the game i
know we all still have lots of questions
but in today's video i want to focus on
the story the lore and some of the
biggest mysteries that we do not know
yet about hogwarts legacy to me it all
starts with number one here what did the
main character survive this could indeed
be the event that kicks off the game is
it some sort of goblin attack is it
perhaps the sudden emergence of the
power of our character because we still
don't know exactly how our character
ties into this so-called ancient magic
and what exactly we can do but in the
developer interview and even in the blog
post they posted after the sony state of
play it's clear that this is something
significant and something that we are
meant to speculate about they even go as
far as saying that our character starts
out a little bit like harry at hogwarts
they're kind of a celebrity because they
survived something i don't think it's
going to be the killing curse we know
that harry was supposedly the only one
who would survive that and of course
this game takes place well before that
plus even if that wasn't the case it
would just be kind of weird if it was
the exact same thing so i do think it's
going to be something different and i
also wonder if we tragically lose our
parents or lose our family at the start
of the game because it seems clear that
professor figg is kind of acting as that
hagrid-like character who's introducing
us to the wizarding world and that leads
us directly into number two why are we
starting at hogwarts as a fifth year
this is actually one of the things that
some fans aren't too happy about because
they want to do all seven years i get it
but i actually think avalanche had a
really good reason at least internally
for wanting it to start at the fifth
years because then they said that
anything would be on the table they
wouldn't have to necessarily hold back
because if you're dealing with a
character that's only 11 years old then
obviously there are some things that you
just don't want to show that character
going through in a game like this but as
a fifth year a little bit older a little
bit more mature so there are certainly
more darker story elements that they can
then explore but that's the real world
reason for this what is the in-game
reason for this i don't know that we
ever have anything like this in canon
before we've had characters getting
expelled that we can look to who don't
finish hogwarts and then i'm sure there
are situations where characters may
transfer between durmstrang and hogwarts
and there are a couple of popular
theories around this one of them is that
perhaps we were homeschooled and that
our parents didn't want us necessarily
going to school and they just trained us
at home instead of going to a wizarding
school but maybe it's something even
deeper than that maybe there's a reason
that our character was marked long ago
as being an individual who does not need
to attend hogwarts perhaps there was a
fear that our character is going to have
the potential to grow into some great
villain maybe because of who their
family is but more on that later number
three what ancient magical abilities
will we unlock these first three here i
think they're all gonna tie very closely
together why does our character survive
why are we starting as a fifth year and
then what are these ancient magical
abilities that apparently our character
is the only one who has at one point in
the lead up for this game they described
it as our character having the unique
ability to perceive and master ancient
magic but then at the playstation state
of play they talked about ran rock
actually wanting to use our character to
get some of these abilities for himself
so to me this says that it is something
that can be transferred in a way i
talked about this a little bit in
another video but i think what it's
going to boil down to is that our
character has this ability to somehow
see and maybe even manipulate ancient
magic to unlock certain areas of the
wizarding world we see a little bit of
this with professor figg when it seems
like our character is kind of putting
their hand on the wall and they have the
ability to open these portals or even
close these portals i guess in some
cases so i think it's more a power of
detection and that is one of the reasons
that ran rock thinks okay he needs to
get to us so we can show him where they
are and then once we sort of unlock the
area wherever it may be then he can go
in and get the power i think there are
actually going to be multiple powers
hidden throughout the world that only
our character has the ability to get
into now two of these they actually show
a little bit in the trailer they show us
calling lightning down from above and
then i personally think that the little
dash ability that looks very similar to
the death eaters apparating from the
harry potter movies which for those of
you who read the books know that's not
how it was supposed to be only voldemort
had the ability to fly and then
apparition was totally different so i
don't know if they're going to be tying
that sort of teleportability to what we
already have seen in movies or if it's
going to be connected to the ancient
magic and these special powers that only
our character can unlock let's move on
to number four though we've already
touched on ran rock a little bit and i
want to know is ran rock actually the
main villain that's certainly how the
trailers seem to be building it up is
that ranrock is leading this goblin
rebellion that he is the main villain of
the game we see him having that argument
with rookwood and rook what appears to
indicate that there is something ranrock
isn't telling him which to me puts
ranrock in sort of the position of power
there he's the one kind of setting that
up
who is this child you're not telling me
but to me it would not be a good
wizarding world story without some sort
of twist i cannot see ran rock being the
only villain maybe he is indeed the main
villain i personally hope there's
someone else kind of behind the curtain
pulling this and we actually come to
sort of understand ran rock before the
game is over but i do think there is a
decent chance he isn't the main villain
which i think would be fascinating for
number five we talked about rookwood a
bit there does he work for the ministry
as soon as all of these names started
coming out fans of course started
looking for connections to the original
harry potter series and rookwood is a
name we all jumped on right away of
course augustus rookwood was a death
eater who served lord voldemort now in
the first wizarding war he was a spy who
worked as an unspeakable in the
department of mysteries he would later
be imprisoned at azkaban and then of
course he was part of that mass breakout
and he went and served as a death eater
again but when it comes to unspeakables
there's really not a lot we know
department of mysteries of course a lot
of that even went unsolved in the
original series a lot of fans wanted to
know what is behind the veil and those
were some questions that were kind of
just left unanswered now we can look to
a quote from arthur weasley in the books
where he says from the department of
mysteries top secret no idea what they
get up to and that of course is talking
about unspeakables remember arthur
worked at the ministry of magic so if
anybody would have a chance of knowing
it would possibly have been him we do
know that some of them studied love in
the love chamber also time and the time
chamber there was another one called the
thought chamber and then of course the
death chamber which is where sirius
black fell into the veil and died now
what does our rookwood and hogwarts
legacy have to do with all this i don't
know i think he's almost certainly a
descendant or hold on i guess it would
be ancestor of augustus rookwood and
personally i think it would be a really
interesting tie-in if he is actually on
the inside with the ministry he
certainly seems to be a shady character
in the trailer but again these trailers
can easily manipulate us and we could be
looking at a twist in the game alright
let's move on to number six and i want
to know which weasleys will we meet at
hogwarts now i point you back to the
playstation blog post not the most
recent one but the one that came out
after that sony say to play there was a
line that said you may even come across
some familiar names like a weasley or
two so i think we could just about take
it to the bank they're gonna be weasleys
in this game now that we know the date
we know the rough time frame of this we
can kind of work our way backwards and
try and figure out who could these
weasleys be then again we do not know
all the weasleys there were certainly
quite a few of them but i think it's
likely that we could be meeting the
father or maybe the uncles of septimus
weasley who was born in approximately
1910. now septimus is the father of
arthur weasley and the reason i say that
we may meet his father or uncles is
because it seems likely to me that they
would be most likely to be male children
as it was a big deal when jenny was born
because they said she was the first
female weasley in several generations
now again they've got some wiggle room
there it doesn't definitively say the
exact timeline of when we had female
versus male weasleys born but if they
really really stick to the canon
hardcore then it could very well be the
father and or uncles of septimus number
seven i can't wait to find out more
about the curse involving sebastian
sallow and his family this is something
that they outright said in the trailer
they said he is dealing with a family
curse so is it him affected is it
someone else in his family it seems like
he is trying to find something for his
sister in the trailer a lot of people
are speculating that could potentially
be a werewolf i think that's a
possibility i'll throw another one out
there what about a blood male addiction
this is actually what happened with
nagini nagini was a maledictus that
suffered from a blood maladiction that
ultimately made her transform into a
large snake and permanently into a large
snake now of course this was kind of
added after the fact of the original
canon and we learned about it through
fantastic beasts but still i do think we
have to consider it as another
possibility among others this could be
quite a few things here this could be
something completely new that they
invent for the game i think that's
certainly some room where they have that
creative freedom they can explore a bit
and now speaking of sebastian let's get
to number eight because we know about
the gryffindor companion we know about
the hufflepuff companion but we did not
see a ravenclaw companion so i want to
know who is the ravenclaw companion and
i'll even give you a bonus one here is
there more than one companion for each
house it certainly seems like that's
kind of how they were setting it up at
least in terms of this initial trailer
that we saw for gameplay but i don't
know i think it'd be a great surprise if
they actually ended up having more than
one companion per house but when it
comes specifically to the ravenclaw one
i want to know why they held it back and
it makes me wonder if there's somebody
that we would somehow recognize or if
there's somebody that is very integral
to the story and they're just not ready
to unveil them yet i'm not really sure
the reason but i can't wait to find out
who it is okay when it comes to number
nine this one here could have major
major ramifications for the overall game
and how it plays out and that question
is our character a descendant of merlin
i gotta credit my buddy expect to go
here i believe he is the first one where
i saw this he's certainly not the only
one who said it but i got to give a lot
of credit to him for coming up with that
theory we know that merlin is mentioned
a number of times in the trailer we see
the name of merlin on the window in
professor benz's history magic classroom
we've had all this talk about ancient
magic and who is more ancient of course
than merlin one of the most powerful
wizards who ever lived even in the
wizarding world universe of harry potter
i personally think merlin would be a fun
way to kind of bring in folks who aren't
necessarily harry potter fans who maybe
they don't know the history of
gryffindor hufflepuff ravenclaw
slytherin but hey merlin i recognize
that name merlin is an incredibly famous
wizard even outside the world of harry
potter so i personally think it'd be
fascinating if our character is a
descendant of him and that's kind of
what i was alluding to earlier about why
does our character start as a fifth year
what are the magical abilities that we
unlock perhaps there was some sort of
prophecy made about a descendant of
merlin and how they were potentially
going to be the downfall of the whole
wizarding world i could certainly see
that being a reason for the ministry to
maybe hide away this wizard and pretend
that they don't know magic and hope that
they never show any signs of magic now
if something like this were to happen
you could certainly see another group of
wizards saying hey hey hey hold on we
can't take this prophecy as 100 truth
we're gonna have to let this person
choose for themselves and we know that
choice is going to play a big part in
this game so i think this theory is
pretty close to spot on i don't know if
it's gonna be exactly merlin but i
definitely think that our character has
some sort of special magical tie to a
famous witcher wizard from the past and
speaking of famous witches and wizards
what about the headmaster or
headmistress that is number 10 who will
be the headmaster or headmistress in
hogwarts legacy i think it comes down to
three possibilities and i break it all
down for you in the video on the right
side of your screen now as always thank
you all so much for watching i'll talk
to you again soon